I know you told us a great story
beforehand about turning certain
situations around which I thought was
really skillful and observant on your
part what are some other tips for let's
say it's the first day of shooting and
your meeting with actors and you're
going you're going to deal with all
kinds of people people pleasers we
talked about being a people pleaser ones
that are going to try you a little bit
maybe ones that are a little bit
intimidated by you they don't know how
to approach you what's your way of
putting people at ease in those quick
moments because maybe there's not a lot
of time to really measure it's a hard
thing to explain or teach somebody I
think you just have to be able to look
at a situation have the courage to do
whatever is necessary to make it right
if nesting know if that's what's what's
going on but you know I think if you're
confident it comes across to other
people and they feel a little bit better
a little more comfortable around you and
if you're timid they're going to sense
that especially an actor because there's
they're trained to sense what's going on
in someone else's world right across
from them they're going to sense what's
going on in your world and if you give
them confidence and you give them
something that makes them feel like
they're being taken care of they're
going to like that and they're going to
want to reciprocate hopefully it's it's
hard to explain that though you have to
be able to get to be capable of that
yourself and my that's why I think at
least so in that moment just knowing how
to read someone yeah being able to read
someone in just maybe
always making sure that you're doing
your best to make them look good even if
you don't think they're doing good job
if you are you're if you're doing your
job right they'll look good regardless
as best as they can look and I think as
long as you're doing your job the right
way we can't really like control anybody
else is going to do but you can at least
try to get the best out of it you know
sure so because that would be my advice
like no matter it you're gonna have
problems like at some point no matter
what but how you handle that problem is
going to be what makes or breaks a
situation sometimes you can sometimes
salvage things that are not you know you
look at it from the outside of what
happened there but if you if you look at
the footage you're like oh okay and if
it if its treated properly and with
respect and the camera then you can do a
lot with not very much sometimes
you